Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
My goodness. GPT-4 barely came out just
a few days ago, and plugin support has
already arrived. What does that mean? It
means supercharging GPT-4 by letting it
build on other applications. That is going to
be a game changer. Here are a few incredible
examples that showcase the power of this
system so you can also get more out of it.
One, meal planning. Now, you may be wondering
why we are using a powerful mathematical system,
Wolfram Alpha for a meal, but you’ll see,
just wait a moment. Now we are asking for one
restaurant recommendation and a simple recipe for
the next day. And now, watch the magic of plugins
happen. ChatGPT recommends us a restaurant, and,
here comes the first plugin - this allows us to
just click here and reserve a table. Then, we
get our recipe recommendation, chickpea salad,
and now comes the magic: Wolfram Alpha
immediately helps us calculate the amount
of calories in the meal. Wow. Finally, if we like
what we are seeing here, with the third plugin,
ordering the ingredients is just one click away.
Now that is what I call an amazing assistant.
And don’t forget, this is a chat assistant, so if
we are looking for something with fewer calories,
we can just ask again and it will calculate
and arrange everything for us. I love it.
And while we are talking about having
an assistant, check this out. Two. Here,
we are interested in knowing a little
more about the Oscar winner movies and
their box office performance compared
to others. And, hold on to your papers,
and look at that! It is browsing the internet,
tells us what is searched for, where it clicked,
it now knows about the awards, looks up box
office performance, and then, the most important:
synthesizes all this information and boils it
down to what we asked for. That is incredible.
And it cites its sources too, so if we
are asking about something critical,
like the good Fellow Scholars we are, we
can also double-check ourselves. So good!
And if we give it an image, it tells us what
it depicts. That is already quite cool in
and of itself, but now comes the assistant
part. Without touching any software tool,
and requiring any sort of computer expertise, we
can just write a line and ask it to resize it,
then, make it grayscale. You know what,
little AI, give it a green tint. Finally,
we can ask for the foreground only, and
a download link. Now, don’t get me wrong,
none of these tasks are difficult to someone who
can code or use some other piece of software to
accomplish this. But, you don’t need any of
that now. Just imagine how many millions of
people will be able to use the power of today’s
computers without needing to be able to code
or buy a bunch of software and figure out how
they work. This is going to change the world.
We can also upload a file with a bunch
of data and ask GPT-4 to try to make some
sense of it. And it does that beautifully.
This is low-key amazing: what it has been
given is just a bunch of numbers, and it had
to find out what part of this is interesting
and why, and it also visualized it in a
way that is easy to consume for a human.
Now let’s ask for something a little
different. This is not a hard problem at all,
but it requires a bit of mathematics. I
wonder what is going to happen here? Yes,
first it writes up two variables, and
with those, a system of equations,
and of course, now we need to solve
it. So, does it? Yes! Okay, but how?
Whoa! Look! It even writes a simple computer
program for it, for which it shows us the full
source code, so we can actually redo or check the
calculations ourselves. Or even extend it to more
complex examples. Here, not just problem solving
is happening. Teaching is also happening! So cool!
And finally, here comes the bombshell. Writing
a plugin for ChatGPT is not that difficult,
here OpenAI creates a toy example in
minutes. But wait. Are you seeing what
I am seeing? They are using ChatGPT to
write a plugin for ChatGPT. My goodness!
We can use ChatGPT to improve itself.
This requires a little human help,
but it is possible. And all this will open
up the world of computers, and creativity
for millions and millions of people, all around
the world. And quite possibly all this for free,
or close to free. What a time to be alive! I feel
that we are witnessing history in the making. Wow.
And all this happened just in the last
few days! How cool is that? The rate of
progress in AI research is nothing short of
amazing. Remember, GPT-2 could barely finish
our sentences and was not that useful, and just
two more papers down the line, here we are. So,
what do you think? What will GPT-6 be capable
of? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!